Hello, welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
My name is Angela Lang. I'm glad that
you've tuned in. We are going on an
excursion through the word of God. So,
go get your Bibles, get your pens and
pencils or your iPads so you could take
notes as we go through this wonderful
word of God. Well, thank you for your
prayers and your support of this
worldwide ministry. It is very much
appreciated. Well, today we have three
wonderful guests. Not guests, they're
regulars. They're not guests. They're
they are home and you are our family.
So, we invite you into our hearts and
into the studio. And today we have three
wonderful panel. Let's start with uh
Pastor Denzy. Welcome.
>> Thank you for the encouragement.
By God's grace, we seek to answer these
questions and ask for the blessing of
his holy spirit.
>> Amen. And Pastor Johnson,
>> it's wonderful to be here. Boy, you
really entice us on an excursion to the
word of God. Can't wait. This is going
to be blessed by God's grace.
>> Amen. Yes, it is. And my most favorite
person, Pastor John.
>> I receive that. Good to see you, honey.
>> Welcome.
>> Where the book ends.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. You and me.
>> Yeah. What do you enjoy about this
wonderful Q&A?
>> We never know what people are going to
ask, and it always sends us down a
rabbit hole to discover. There's always
something we don't know.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. I'm going to just read
something real short before we go into
our prayer. And this is about the Bible.
The Bible contains the mind of God, the
way of life, the path once trod, its
teachings, holy laws so deep, a sacred
promise it will keep. It is the
traveler's trusty map, a comfort on the
weary on the weary lap. It holds the
light to guide your feet and makes the
bitter moment sweet.
>> Read it to be wise and true. Let its
wisdom work for in you. A mind of
wealth, a river's flow, the greatest
friend you could ever know. And that's
the word of God. And so I am so looking
forward to this Q&A and looking for
answers from the questions that you send
in. Pastor Denzy, would you please open
with prayer?
>> Sure. Let's go to the Lord in prayer.
>> Our marvelous and wonderful heavenly
father, we thank you Lord that you are
approachable even though we know that
you're a holy and God that should be
respected. You tell us that it is a
throne of grace and for this we are
grateful. We ask Lord for the blessing
of your Holy Spirit. Give us the answers
that your children need in this time of
need. We pray Lord for your blessing
upon each one of us and also on those
that are listening to this program. We
pray that you will guide them in
understanding your word. Thank you for
the holy scriptures that make us wise
unto salvation. and thank you that you
have preserved it so that we can enjoy
it today, study it today, and help to
prepare for the soon return of our Lord
and Savior. In these things, we thank
you and ask. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Maybe you have questions that you would
like to send in. You can send your
questions. You can text it in to
6182283975
or you can email us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. You
can Instagram us at
3abn_official.
Okay, let's go on on our Bible
excursion.
>> Buckle our seat belt.
>> Buckle your seat belts. Here we go.
Pastor John,
do the seven churches in Revelation
represents all Christian churches or
specific groups? This is from William in
Tennessee.
>> Thank you, William. You know the seven
churches not only represent seven time
periods but more specifically seven
conditions and these conditions can be
prevalent at all times in history and in
all denominations. For example, the
church of Ephesus, the church of Ephesus
was the beginning of the Christian
church. But the Lord had in in
Revelation 2:5, he said, "I have
something against you. You have lost
your first love. You have left your
first love." So if you are a Christian
that has along the way left your first
love who is Jesus Christ,
>> the message here for you is repent and
do the first work. And so we could lose
our first love. It doesn't really matter
what denomination we are. Then the
church of Smyrna was the persecuted
church. This church was encouraged.
There are Christians being persecuted.
You might be in a family that does not
like anything about Christianity and you
might be enduring persecution in your
relationship because of your walk with
Christ. The Bible says, 'Do not fear any
of those things which you are about to
suffer. Revelation 2 and:e 10. And the
time frame it says, "Some of you may be
cast in prison. You may be tested. You
may have tribulation." Historically, the
tribulation was from 303 to 313 AD. That
was the literal application. But the
Lord says, "If you're persecuted, be
faithful unto death and I will give you
a crown of life." That's the church of
Smyrna. than the Pergamist church. This
church was stumbling through immorality.
Revelation 2:14 and 15. They held the
doctrine of Balum and the doctrine of
the nicicoatans which simply meant they
did not believe that their spiritual
life was impacted by their moral life.
>> So they were participating in sexual
immorality and did not think that that
would impact their walk with Christ.
Well, the Lord says, you know, you you
have those among you that hold the
doctrine of Balum and also commit sexual
immorality and hold the doctrine of
nickelins. Meaning,
>> if you don't believe that your spiritual
life is impacted by your moral life,
then you're incorrect.
>> So, that's something we must repent from
if we are stumbling in that area.
>> Then, Thotyra was a church during its
time. It was a church that experienced
spiritual compromise. In Revelation
2:20, it says, "I have a few things
against you." and talked about that
woman Jezebel and during the dark ages
the church mixed with the church of Rome
that polluted the teaching of the church
and that was the age of compromise. Then
Sardis which was the church of
commenation the church of brotherly love
the revival of the gospel. This is a
church that the Lord had nothing
negative to say about it. And so if you
are walking with the Lord in a strong
relationship and you're working uh your
love is growing for Christ there is
nothing negative. But now finally the
age in which we are the church of
Leodysia today the lukewarm church the
danger is this they are wretched
miserable poor blind and naked and don't
even know it
>> so we're living in an age where if you
are in that condition and you think
you're all right the thing to do is
repent and accept the Isal that you may
see your true condition repent and come
back to the Lord
>> seven conditions also seven church
periods
>> now which one is brotherly love
>> Philadelphia Okay. I thought you said
Sardis.
>> I know. Sardis was the one where they
had they were spiritually challenged.
>> Okay. Those are how many conditions?
>> Seven conditions, seven churches.
>> Wow. Amen. Thank you so much. Good.
Let's move on to Pastor Johnson. This is
an interesting question, so listen up.
>> Okay.
>> Can you please explain divorce and
salvation? I committed adultery in my
marriage and although my husband says he
has forgiven me, he often brings it up
during disagreements and calls my calls
my faith into question.
>> He also uses hurtful languages toward
me.
>> I have considered divorce but I keep
coming back to Mark chapter 10 and
struggle with what is right. This is
from Angel in Jamaica.
>> Well, thank you so much, Sister Angel,
for being willing to make yourself
vulnerable and ask that question. There
are people out there that need to hear
what the Lord says about this. So, if
you will allow me, sister, because there
are many who treat marriage as a trivial
thing. Let's just establish for those
who are wondering what the Lord says
about adultery. Sexual relations outside
of marriage are a violation of God's
law. As it says in Exodus 20:14, "Thou
shalt not commit adultery." And again,
that's for the viewers who are
wondering, does God take this seriously?
He does. But you, my sister,
you have acknowledged your wrongdoing
and you are seeking to make things
right. And this is very important
because there's something I want to talk
about here. First of all, as a pastor,
unless it's an issue of safety and some
other things, I would never promote
divorce. The Lord wants us to reconcile
with each other. But God also honors
confession. He honors repentance. He
honors the desire to restore that which
has been broken because this is what he
does with us every day,
>> right?
>> He forgives us. Now, the Bible says that
if we confess our sins, he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness. And
I want you to remember that word just
because it also says in Romans 1:1 17
that the just shall live by faith. So
when you confess your sins to the Lord,
you are forgiven. You are justified.
Now, what is that? Look at this text. It
says, "Being justified by faith, we have
peace with God." Praise the Lord. You
have peace with God. What is this
justification? Justification means to be
declared righteous by God. Not made
righteous by works, but counted
righteous through the faith of Jesus
Christ. And yes, sanctification is
coming. But when you've asked for
forgiveness, the Lord declares you
clean. Amen.
>> But it is indeed the work of the devil
to bring up our past and hit us with it.
>> And that can be very very difficult.
That is why you got to have faith in
your justification. However, what your
husband is experiencing is part of the
fact that it can take people a while to
heal. So here's what I would suggest. I
would suggest that if you've done
counseling to get over the cause of
adultery, praise the Lord, but maybe
consider counseling again to help your
husband learn to forgive and let it go.
Specifically that. And then I'm going to
give you some homework. There's a
saying, take it to the Lord in prayer. I
would like you in the morning,
>> in the afternoon, and in the evening,
don't be deep about it. Grab your
husband and pray together. Yes.
>> You know, praying together brings people
together.
>> Yes, it does. Let's just do that. Let
the Lord work. And I have one more thing
I'd like you to do. When I was in
marital counseling before Anissa and I
got married, premarital counseling, we
were told to take turns reading 1
Corinthians 13 back to each other. One
night she'd read it to me over the
phone. The next night I'd read it to
her. So while you were counseling, pray
together. Read the word together. And
watch the Holy Ghost knit your marriage
by God's grace. Praise God. Beautiful
answer. Um, you mentioned a text
justified peace with God. Do you have
that text?
>> That is Romans chapter 5 and verse one.
>> Romans 5 verse1. Thank you. Wonderful.
Good answer. Praise God. Amen. There is
hope. And he said it. Go to the Lord in
prayer. Uh, Pasadini,
can you explain the burnt offerings in
Leviticus 1? Why were the endrails and
legs washed with water? And were they
burned along with the rest of the
offering? This is from Norman.
>> Thank you, Norman. It's a wonderful
question. And there in Leviticus chapter
1, I'm going to go ahead and read verse
8 and N that brings this out. And the
priest, Aaron's sons, shall lay the
parts, the head, and the fat in order
upon the wood that is on the fire which
is upon the altar. But his inwards and
his legs shall he wash in water, and the
priest shall burn all on the altar to be
a burnt sacrifice and offering made by
fire of a sweet savor unto the Lord.
Now, why wash these things if you're
going to burn them?
>> It's a very good question, but God is a
God of order. Notice that everything is
laid on the in order
>> upon the wood. And even the wood was
laid in order. God was uh very detailed
about things. And also, he wants things
to be done in order. But this washing,
why do it? And this is ins in insight of
say I'm trying to speak Spanish. I I put
in a Spanish word.
>> So here is something interesting. This
is a symbolic symbolical of the
cleanliness that God desires of us even
inside.
>> And he wants to work in our lives in
such a way that we are clean on the
outside and clean on the inside. And
this is a symbolical act that was done
here that later would be sacrificed or
burnt up. So even the part lay the parts
in order, lay the word in order. I'm
going to bring to you in
the book of John chap 20 verse 6 and 7.
Then Simon Peter came following him and
went into the tomb and he saw the linen
cloths lying there and the handkerchief
that had been around his head that is
Jesus Christ that was around his head
not lying with the linen cloths but fold
it together in a place by itself. Now
why would Jesus after resurrecting from
the dead take time to fold everything
and put it neatly and in order? God is a
God of order and it's very very
interesting and that's why in 1
Corinthians 14:40 he says let all things
be done decently and in order but this
act of washing the inards uh is part of
the cleansing that needs to be inside
you know inside our minds can take all
kinds of evil can take place murders
adultery and God wants us to be clean on
the inside as well this is a process
this is a process of sanctification that
has been talked about. And so we
cooperate with God and let him wash us
inside and out. There's a part that we
have to do. We have to cooperate with
the Lord so that we can be clean on the
outside and on the inside.
>> Amen. And it the sacrifices represented
Jesus, right?
>> Yes. Absolutely.
>> Yes. The ultimate. All right. Thank you
so much, Pastor Deny. Okay, Pastor John.
According to Revelation 6:15,
the wicked living will hide in the caves
and in the rocks of the mountains at
Jesus's second coming. Will they have
one last opportunity to repent? This is
from Lucelli in Louisiana.
>> Okay. Well, thank you, Lucelli. Quickly,
the answer is no
>> because probation would have closed at
that time.
>> Yeah. by the time they're running. And
Revelation 6:14 talks about that. But
Revelation 6:15 says, "And the kings of
the earth, the great men, the rich men,
the commanders, the mighty men, every
slave and every free man hid themselves
in the caves and in the rocks of the
mountains." And the next verse says,
"And they said to the rocks in the
mountains, hide us from the face of him
who sits on the throne and from the
wrath of the lamb. For the great day of
his wrath has come, and who shall be
able to stand? Now, I want you to get
that.
To the wicked, the lamb is wrathful.
>> To the righteous, the lamb is peaceful.
>> Yes.
>> How could you've never seen a wrathful
lamb? People don't get chased by lambs,
growling at them.
>> But that's the position. That's the
position that the wicked have. To him,
to those who are saved, he is our
savior. We have waited for him. He will
save us. But to the wicked, all of a
sudden the wrath, the lamb,
>> who is the most subtle beast ever
created is now wrathful.
>> It's because they have spurned his
mercy.
>> They have turned their backs on his
invitation to be saved. And that's the
last person they want to see. Yeah.
>> So the answer is no. And here's the
reason why. There's a declaration made
before that time. Revelation 22:1. Now,
I want to emphasize the word still. I
want you to grab that because when I
read this,
Revelation 22:1 is going to emphasize
what a person was up until that time.
>> That's right.
>> And what they're going to continue to be
after this healing is done.
>> Revelation 22:1.
He who was unjust, let him be unjust
still. Why? Because he's been unjust up
to that point. Right?
>> That's that's what he's going to be.
That's why character development is so
vitally important. What you are up until
that point of probation closing is what
you're gonna be still.
>> He who is filthy, let him be filthy
still. Watch out with your thoughts and
your behavior. He who is righteous, let
him be righteous still. He who is holy,
let him be holy still. So, it's
important that we develop character
knowing that one day we're going to see
the face of the Lord Jesus Christ. And
if we are holy and righteous, he would
not be a lamb of wrath,
>> but a lamb of hope, a lamb of peace, a
lamb of victory. So what's the best
counsel I can give you? Matthew chapter
24:42.
Watch therefore,
>> for you do not know what hour your Lord
is coming. But know this, that if the
master of the house had known what hour
the thief would come, he would have
watched and not allowed his house to be
broken into. Therefore, you also be
ready. For the Son of Man is coming at
an hour that you do not expect.
>> If you are ready, he is the lamb that
takes away the sin of the world. If you
are not, he is the lamb of wrath.
>> Be ready.
>> Amen. What's that song? Let us watch and
be
>> That's right.
>> He will come. Okay. Now,
>> I know
>> ready to sing it. You
>> got your in your back.
>> So, you want you want to watch and be
ready, don't we? He will come.
Hallelujah. Hallelujah. Amen. Thank you
so much for that. That's the thing you
want to be ready. Amen.
>> Pastor Johnson.
>> Yes, Bill.
>> Why did the people in the Old Testament
live so long before the flood? This is
from John in Georgia.
>> Wow. That is a great question and it
gives us an opportunity to look at the
effects of sin. For those of you all who
are not familiar, uh I'm going to do a
little just some referencing from
Genesis chapter 5. That's where all the
begats are. It says Adam lived 930
years. That's verse 5. Seth his son
lived 912 years. Verse 8. Uh let's jump
down. Jared lived 962 years. Verse 20.
Methuselah lived 969
years. That's verse 27. Almost a
millennium. And that is so different
>> from how long or the lifespan of people
today. And these are not symbolic. No,
>> these are actually how long they live.
It represented a world where human life
had exceptional physical vitality,
remarkable biological strength. But
here's something we don't think about.
They had mental endurance. That's right.
>> You know, you can't live a thousand
years today and keep your mind. I'm in
my 40s. I feel like I'm about to go
crazy now.
>> So clearly things were different then
than they are now. So what happened?
Let's have a look in Genesis 6:3.
There's this text that's often misused
to explain this. It says, "My spirit
shall not always strive with man." God
talking, "Yet his days shall be an 120
years." And that is not God putting a
limitation there. He's talking about how
long the preaching will be before the
flood comes along. But then there was
the flood. Now, all that we read in
Genesis 5 was before the flood. And then
we have the flood, the the uh flood
account in Genesis 7 and 8. God is
talking to Noah in Genesis 6. And look
at the ages after the flood. Here's a
gentleman, Eber 464 years.
>> Pelleg 239 years. And when we go on
down, Isaac 180, that's still old. Jacob
147. And in Deuteronomy 34:7,
Moses lived 120 years. And it still and
it says he was still vigorous, right?
when he died. So, something has clearly
taken place. What is it?
>> Well, there's an obvious thing. There's
the diet.
>> Because if you look at what was the
primary food that was eaten, it says in
Genesis that the herb, the plants, but
when the flood came, God recognizing
that after the flood there wouldn't be
no trees around, he allowed the eating
of clean meats. And you can read in
Genesis where the animals that were
clean went into the ark by sevens. M
>> so that they could eat meat. And there's
clearly clearly a reaction in their
biology. But there's something that I
want to close with. Sin itself
has an effect on our physiology. And you
think I'm just coming at you as a
preacher, but let's be medical. Look
this up. Transgenerational epigenetic
inheritance in mammals. It is scientific
that the way we live affects our
progeny.
>> So what we are seeing, my brother, is
the long-term effects of sin eroding
humankind.
>> But God's going to come and put us back
>> where we were. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. We're going to live forever,
aren't we?
>> Yes, ma'am. And have the mind to do so.
>> Yes. Even Moses didn't lose his vision,
did he? He had his his eyesight was
good. We read that in the Bible. Thank
you, Pastor Ryan, for that. Powerful.
All right, Pastor Dy. This is a little
lengthy question.
I recently went through postpartum
depression caused by birth, trauma, and
previous losses.
I always find myself wondering if having
depression means I don't trust in God.
Does it mean I will be lost because I'm
still on anti-depressants and haven't
healed yet? Is there a relationship
between depression and demon possession?
This is from Rosemary in Kenya. That's a
very good question. And so I tried to
sympathize with this. You're going
through some experience that is really
horrifying. You know you mentioned
postpartum depression, trauma and
previous losses and that is heavy upon
any human being
>> and so also there are chemical changes
taking place the hormonal imbalance for
a period of time and correct me if I'm
wrong but there's hormonal changes
taking place as in the birthing process
>> uh pastor Johnson also studies some
medicine and so you have a question here
does having depression mean I don't
trust has got no
>> because even some medicines can cause
depression and this has been documented
some medicines even cause people to see
things. My sister that recently had some
uh urinary tract infection says she was
seeing puppies that were not really
there. So these things can cause people
difficulties and coping and so you are
taking anti-depressants
doesn't mean that you will be lost
>> but you are seeking for help but this
doesn't mean that you don't trust God
because you obviously trust God in some
areas of your life you can probably
think I'm sure you can think of
experiences where you put yourself in
the hands of the Lord and the Lord
helped you through it and even this you
are concerned about your relationship
with God. You are concerned about your
salvation. You are a believer in Christ.
Continue to trust in him. Believe in
him. Continue to study the holy
scriptures. Let's talk about depression
for a moment. In Matthew 26,
>> uh verse 36, 37, and 38, let's look at
Jesus for a moment. Then Jesus came with
them to a place called Gethsemane and
said to the disciples, "Sit here while I
go and pray over there." And he took
with him Peter and the two sons of
Zebedee. and he began to be sorrowful
and deeply distressed. Then he said to
them, "My soul is exceedingly sorrowful,
even to death. Stay here and watch with
me." These are symptoms of a depression.
It doesn't mean that it was a sin. Even
Jesus entered into some kind of a
depressive state because of the
experience he was going through. But he
did not sin.
>> So,
>> it is not a sin to be depressed. It can
be dangerous if you stay there
>> and you're seeking for help and that's a
good thing.
>> Look at the promises of the Lord. Find
strength in them. Look at Psalms 46 for
example, for example. God is our refuge
and strength, present help in time of
trouble.
>> Read the promises of the Lord and really
focus on your relationship with the
Lord. And you're going to find that as
you think of Jesus, what he's done for
you, the promises of salvation and you
can sing him and you can uh place
yourself in an atmosphere of heaven and
yes, ask the Lord to heal you from this
condition so that he will bring you the
healing and the blessing you need during
this time.
>> Amen.
>> I didn't get to the part about demon
possession because that's another long
topic.
>> Yeah. Let's have a short word of prayer
for Rosemary. Let's bow our heads.
Father in heaven, we come to you in
Jesus' name and we lift up Rosemary. You
see what she's going through, the
depression and all that after having a
child. I ask that your Holy Spirit will
come ever close to her and help her
through this. And Lord, we know that you
don't want her to be this way, but
Father, we you are the burden lifter,
the burden bearer. Amen.
>> So we pray that you'll lift this burden
from her and help her as she uh be with
this wonderful baby that you have given
to her and to raise this child in the
admonition of the Lord. So strengthen
her and keep her in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Pray with her sister.
>> Wonderful.
>> Yes.
She's in the mighty hand of God. All
right. Thank you so much. Let's move on.
All right, Pastor John. This is an
interesting question.
>> Mhm.
>> Has doctrine changed about wearing
jewelry? Some pastors and Christian
musicians are wearing wedding rings and
other jewelry. After I see this, I don't
even want to hear. I I don't want to
hear what comes out of their mouths. And
the person just wrote are. So don't know
who this is.
>> I I sense by this question you're pretty
perturbed by by what you see.
>> You can tell. Let me let me help you uh
calibrate recalibrate. First of all, uh
everybody's at a different place.
>> Yeah.
>> In their walk with Christ. The question
of adornment is established by the
Bible. Two things I want to answer.
First of all, the church's position on
the wearing of jewelry has not changed.
>> Right?
>> But the wedding ban is not a test of
Christian fellowship. So, I'm going to
go ahead and read actual belief number
22. You can go to advent.org, go to
belief number 22, and I've summarized
the section that addresses this. And by
the way, the scriptures are there to
qualify what the statement says. It
says, "While recognizing cultural
differences, our dress is to be simple,
modest, and neat, befitting those whose
true beauty does not consist of outward
adornment, but in the imperishable
ornament of a gentle and quiet spirit."
Very short. But when you look at the
Bible text, it expands on that. Mhm.
>> And people have had the idea that now
the world is affecting the church to a
large degree.
>> And that's something that I've also
noticed myself as a pastor,
>> but we have standards at our church when
it comes to adornments. We don't put
down a thick standard for wedding bands
because the Bible does not make that a
test. The church does not make that a
test to fellowship. And when we study
the impact on different cultures, uh
there's a very important factor there.
But you want to go to my website,
johnlomck.com.
You can go there even now as you listen.
And on my very homepage, scroll down to
the middle and I have a three-part study
on adornment, where jewelry wearing came
from. And this I catapulted, you know,
in 1991 when I met a young lady who was
an Adventist. Her friend was not an
Adventist. She was a Wiccan.
>> She's a W.
>> And she wanted to meet me after I
preached on Sabbath morning.
>> And she said to me, the Adventist girl
said, "My friend wants to meet you, but
I'm not sure she has on her protection."
So I asked the Wiccan, they call
themselves good witches. What do you
mean by protection? She says, "My
jewelry is my protection."
>> And I then catapulted into the study of
that and I found a number of things. And
I'll say this very quickly. In Genesis
35:1-4, when God called Jacob's family
to be sanctified, to go to Bethl to be
sanctified, Jacob said to his household,
"Put away the foreign gods that are
among you. Purify yourselves and change
your garments." In Genesis 35:4, so they
gave Jacob all the foreign gods which
were in their hands and the earrings
which were in their ears and Jacob hid
them or buried them under the oak tree
which was by Sheckchum. They buried
them. Yeah.
>> Because when you follow the story,
Jacob's wife, her father sold these gods
>> and they brought them into their home.
And so Jacob knew that they could not be
they could not be sanctified by wearing
or jewelry and ornament. And so you go
to also to Exodus 35:22 where this topic
continues and you find clearly that um
the position on ornamentation has not
changed. When you recognize your body is
God's temple and just give me a few
seconds more. I need to add this.
>> Yes. Go ahead.
>> I'll take it away from my other time.
>> Yeah.
>> When you study the topic of the wearing
of jewelry and where it came from,
>> it is amazing to find out that the
wearing of jewelry came from the belief
in the immortal soul.
>> Yeah.
>> And this is powerful. this on my on my
website. I have the study there. The the
Egyptians and many foreign cultures
believe that when a person died, their
spirit continued to roam the earth. And
they the gods, they worshiped the sun,
moon, stars. They made their jewels out
of that particular metal. And they
blocked all of the openings believing
that this metal being their god would
stop the spirits from getting into their
body. But the Lord now saying, "I'm your
protection kept them from putting
foreign gods on their on his temple."
>> And when you study the Bible, you'll see
clearly. So there's quite a bit. Go to
my website once again, you'll see the
full study because I want to do this
justice. But the position on the church
when it comes to wearing of ornaments,
it hasn't changed. So our organists, our
pianists do not wear earrings and
necklaces. If they have a wedding band,
we don't make that assessed fellowship.
>> Right. Amen. But what do you always say
for leadership?
>> For leadership for for membership no for
for vis for for visitors no standards
right
>> for membership standards for leadership
high standards. We must be an example.
That's why I don't wear a wedding band.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you so much. I hope
that was clear. Maybe you've just tuned
in and you say, "Hey, I want to send a
question in." You can text it to
618-2283975
or you can email your question at
bibleqa3abn.tv.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. You
can go in at Instagram 3abn_official.
So send your questions in. We'd love to
hear from you. Okay, Pastor Johnson,
this is a good short question. Is
drinking water allowed during fasting
and prayer? This is from
I'm a Gia Wanman in Nigeria.
>> Amen. Oh, thank you for that question.
First of all, yes, please do drink water
uh when you are fasting. And let's
approach this biblically and we'll look
at it a little bit medically. You know,
there are different ways that you can
fast, but let's look at the fast where
one is abstaining from food. Fasting is
not about punishing the body. We're not
trying to earn favor with God. We're not
trying to prove our spiritual strength
or fortitude. God does not want us to
exercise self harm, physical
destruction. It is not a test of our
endurance. In fact, if you look at, we
don't have time to go there. Isaiah 58,
God talks about what he's looking for
when we discuss fasting because some
people can go through the motions and
then there's no God in it at all. So
fasting is actually about obtaining
spiritual focus, humility before God,
removing distractions and drawing closer
to him. And we actually have an example
of what fasting does by looking at
Christ himself. This is from Luke 4 13
and 14. It says, "And when the devil had
ended all the temptation, this is Christ
in the wilderness fasting all that time,
he departed from him." The devil
departed from Jesus for a season and
Jesus returned. Look at this. in the
power of the spirit into Galilee and
there went out a fame of him through all
the region. This is the effect of the
fasting in the power of the spirit he
was focused. He was ready for his
mission and that is what we are looking
for that focus that connection with God.
But I want you to notice something.
We're going to look at the same story
from Matthew 4 and verse 2. Jesus in the
wilderness. It says, "And when he had
fasted 40 days and 40 nights, he was
afterward and hungered."
>> Huh?
>> And say was thirsty. You see that? So
the emphasis is on hunger, not thirst.
The text does not suggest total
dehydration. That is not what took
place. Jesus abstained from food. Now
let's be a little medical. The human
body cannot survive very long without
water. No. the fact to refuse water
completely is to move into danger. And
when we do that deliberately, we can be
being a bit presumptuous. And that's not
what we want. Now, let's close with some
medical/biblical stuff. Let's put it
together. If you read Daniel chapter 1,
it becomes clear as Daniel and his
friends choose not to be defiled and
say, "Give us pulse and water." It
becomes clear that what you eat affects
your mind because after this diet we are
told not only were they better looking
they were wiser than everyone else. This
is what we are seeking to have the focus
based on what we put in our bodies on
God because it is clear what we eat
affects our minds.
>> Yes.
>> Did you know
>> that severe dehydration can lead to
confusion and even hallucination? That
is the opposite of what we're looking
for. So, please drink water when you
fast. And remember, the objective of the
fast is getting closer to and focusing
on God.
>> Amen. Isn't Jesus the water of life?
>> Oh, he is. Come on, preach it now.
>> Jesus. I love it. I'm so mad I didn't
think of that.
>> Holy Spirit just said to me, Jesus is
the water of life. Amen.
>> That's right.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that. A
wonderful response. Okay, Pastor Dy,
your question is a little lengthy, so
let's go.
How do you repent for not loving God?
Every so often, I get the sense that I'm
an impostor fighting to look like a good
Christian.
>> How do I deal with the idea that if I
work for God, I'm doing it to buy his
presence? If I step back to allow him to
move me to do his good pleasure, I'm
just waiting for a voice in my head to
tell me what to do, which could be very
well be me working in my own power.
Would it be bad if I resolved that I
might never be good enough for heaven? I
don't think I'll make it, but I'll try
to do what is right by pointing others
to him. This is from Danielle. Give us
some hope.
>> Yeah,
>> Danielle, you know there are a lot of
things you said that bring some concern.
Of course, you are struggling and this
is uh important to know that you are
also looking for help
>> and the Lord is going to help you. Uh
it's a process of course and the
question is how does one repent from not
loving God. This is almost a shocking
statement. We have to be careful because
not all the thoughts that are in our
mind are good thoughts. You know sa
Satan has the capability to put thoughts
in our mind. You can see this in the
experience of Jesus and the disciples.
So let us be careful with our thoughts
so that they are not leading us away
from the Lord. Away from the Lord. So,
uh, how does one repent from loving God?
The Bible shows us that it is the
goodness of God that leads us to
repentance.
>> Amen.
>> Seek the Lord. Let me read to you Romans
2:4. Or do you despise the riches of his
goodness, forbearance, and
longsuffering, not knowing that the
goodness of God leads you to repentance?
Search for the Lord with all your heart.
Now you mentioned about loving God and
hopefully you will take time I encourage
you to take time read Isaiah 53.
>> This is talking about Jesus sacrificing
for us. Read it carefully. Study it with
prayerful
consideration.
>> Give thought to what you're reading.
also look at the life of Christ,
especially the the the chapters where
he's entering upon his suffering for him
struggling there in Gethsemane. Great
drops of blood, sweat like great drops
of blood pouring from his head because
of the great suffering he was going
through because he loves you.
>> Yes.
>> And look at his sacrifice. Every
pounding of the nails said to him, "I
love you. I love you and I died for
you." And his goodness, his goodness
will lead you to repentance and a pure
love for him. And so be careful with the
thoughts, I am not good enough. You
know,
>> this is a very dangerous thought. I'm
not good enough. Well, God
>> Jesus is good enough. And it is his
sacrifice that really gives us the
opportunity for salvation. That's why
I'm reading to you Ephesians chapter 2
verses 8-10. For by grace you have been
saved through faith, and that not of
yourselves. It is the gift of God.
Salvation is a gift of God, not because
you are good enough.
>> That's right.
>> Not of works, lest anyone should boast.
For we are his workmanship, created in
Christ Jesus for good works, which God
prepared beforehand that we should walk
in them.
>> Yes. Please consider also 1 Peter
chapter 1 verse 18 and 19. Knowing that
you were not redeemed with corruptible
things like silver or gold from your
anal conduct received by tradition from
your fathers, but with the precious
blood of Christ as of a lamb without
blemish and without spot.
>> Jesus is your savior. And Romans chapter
8 verse one, there's therefore now no
condemnation to them that are in Christ
Jesus remain in Christ Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> Beautiful. Danielle, there's hope. Don't
give up. Jesus loves you with an
everlasting love.
>> Amen. Thank you.
>> Let's move on.
>> Oh, this is short. Pastor John, are
women supposed to wear hair coverings to
church? Is it not a sin to do so? No.
Name?
>> Well, is is it a sin not to do so? The
answer is no on both points.
Paul in 1 Corinthians chapter 11 is
addressing a tradition, a cultural
symbol.
>> Yeah.
>> Not a requirement of God in the last
days. And so there were those who when
they went to the temple, they had their
heads covered. Yeah.
>> And when you read this in 1 Corinthians
11:es 1-16, I'll let you do that.
>> But the Bible point out a few things.
They talked about a woman who prays,
prophesies with her head uncovered,
dishonors her head, for that is one of
the in the same as if her head were
shaved. This is 1 Corinthians 11:5. But
it points out a few things. Her husband
is her covering
>> and her hair is her covering. That's
right.
>> These are two things. And so the
Corinthians were trying to they were
those trying to impose cultural uh
practices on the Corinthian believer.
And Paul addressing this entire thing
when he goes down to it and I want to
just end this early so I could address
the prior question.
>> Yeah.
>> But it says in in 1 Corinthians chap
11:15.
>> But if a woman has long hair, it is a
glory to her. For her hair is given to
her for a covering. But if anyone seems
to be contentious, we have no such
custom, nor do the churches of God. So
it's just simply a cultural custom.
That's all it was. Nothing else. So
there are those who say, "Well, you must
No, this is not a cultural custom." No.
>> Paul was addressing a cultural impact,
not a salvific practice.
>> Amen. Right.
>> Amen. And some churches, the women come
in with hats. Yeah,
>> I know that for a fact.
>> Every now and then you wear a hat.
>> Every now and then,
>> but I want to tell you, if you don't
wear a hat, that doesn't mean you're
lost.
>> That's right. All right, let's move on.
>> Okay, Pastor Johnson, this is a lengthy
question. It says, "I'm struggling with
something and I hope you can help me
with clarity.
>> I was married for 16 years and during
that marriage, I dealt with abuse in
many forms and my husband had multiple
affairs. I divorced him and have since
remarried a wonderful man. I was told by
a close family member that I am
considered an adulteress
>> because I am the one who initiated the
the divorce and remarried.
>> I love the Lord and I'm working daily to
grow in my relationship with him. Am I
doing this in vain?
>> Am I certain to go to hell because I
left my abuser? I was humiliated for so
many years trying to stay married and
was humiliated
when I divorced. Now I feel doomed and
it hurts my heart.
>> Should I have stayed married to my first
husband? This is Jamie in Oregon.
>> Hey, Sister Jamie, this is a powerful
question. There are many elements to it.
Let's take on two of them, I think. Um,
first, if your husband had affairs, the
Bible is clear. This is grounds for
divorce and remarry. But what I'd really
like to do if it's okay with you
gentlemen and sister, I want to look at
this this abuse part. There are many
many types of abuse and they are all not
good. But let's let's focus a bit on
physical abuse. There are some things in
scripture
that are not ideal but yet they are
permitted. Like eating meat, for
example, not ideal, they're permitted.
Divorce is one of those things. Jesus
says in Matthew chapter 19:8, "Moses,
because of the hardness of your hearts,
suffered you to put away your wife." So
divorce is one of those things.
>> But some people mistakenly think that
abuse is in that category. It's
something that is not ideal,
>> but it is permitted. And that is wrong.
It is wrong. Abuse is not only
discouraged. I believe abuse is a sin.
Yes. And it is in the Bible. Let's go
ahead and have a look at it. Let's look
at 1 Corinthians chapter 6 19 and 20.
What
>> know ye not that your body is the temple
of the Holy Ghost and you are not your
own?
>> Yeah.
>> And if my body is the temple of the Holy
Ghost and I'm responsible for what I do
to me, how dare I defile somebody else's
temple?
>> Right?
>> And look what the Bible says about that.
1 Corinthians chapter 3:1 17. If any man
defile the temple of God, him shall God
destroy. I think it is clear
>> that abuse is a sin.
>> Yes, it is.
>> It is a sin. We need to come out of
that. Babylon people have mercy.
Husbands, love your wives. Be not bitter
against them. Colossians 3:19. Likewise,
ye husbands, dwell with them, and wives.
I have met some husbands that are being
abused. Spousal abuse is a sin. There is
some counsel. Listen to this counsel. If
a husband is harsh, overbearing, cruel,
or abusive, he has no right to demand
submission. A person is not required by
God to remain in danger, to endure
physical harm, to suffer psychological
destruction. Leave. And if you want to
know where that council came from, you
can go a little book called Adventist
Home. Interesting that council is in
there. You are not supposed to stay when
you are in danger. I have seen it lead
to death.
>> Yes. No, but can we remarry? And this is
a thing where preachers go back and
forth. We have established that it is a
sin. But there are some, and I am one. I
remember what I said to my wife on my
wedding day. And if I begin to abuse
Anessa, first of all, my father would
kill me. But if I begin to abuse her,
that is a breach of marital vows.
>> Yes.
>> It is a form of idolatry. It is.
>> And so I believe,
>> yes,
>> that you can remarry. But I don't know
everything. I would like to toss it to
you preachers. What do you say, Pastor
Lang?
>> On the issue of abuse, don't stay in the
relationship. And the Lord is not uh now
sequestering you for a life of misery
all by yourself.
>> No.
>> No. Denzy, what do you think, sir?
>> Should not stay in the homem
>> should leave the home. And of course,
pray for the husband. See if there's a
period of time. See if the leaving will
lead that person to repentance. But
unless the person gives himself
completely to the Lord, do not go back.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Amen. Yeah. Get out of there. Run.
Amen. Oh, for the sake of time, we got
to move on. Thank you so much, Pastor
Denzy.
In 1st Samuel 16:5, Samuel performed the
purification right for Jesse and his
sons. What is the purification right?
This is from Eva in California.
>> Uh, thank you, Eva. I just want to add,
you know, you know, some some of these
uh people that are abusers, they say,
"Oh, they want me to go back to church."
Uh you have to give it time. You have to
give it time before you say, "Let's go
back." And it's on the grounds of
counseling with a with a pastor and uh
be careful with this thing
>> professional.
>> Let's go to 1st Samuel 16:5. And he
said, "Peaceably I come to sacrifice
unto the Lord. Sanctify yourselves and
come with me to the sacrifice." and he
sanctified Jesse and his sons and called
them to the sacrifice. So what's
involved here? What's involved here?
When we look in other places in the
Bible, for example, Exodus chapter 19,
let's go to verse 10. Then the Lord said
to Moses, "Go to the people and
consecrate them today and tomorrow, and
let them wash their clothes,
>> and let them be ready for the third day.
For on the third day, the Lord will come
down upon Mount Si in the sight of all
the people." Exodus 19. This is before
Exodus 20 where the ten commandments are
found. So the people were to be ready to
be in the presence of the Lord. So
washing their clothes, washing their
bodies was part of the process of being
consecrated and sanctified. So we
continue uh it continues there 11:12.
Read it, read it, read it, read it, read
it. Uh verse 14 is where I pick up. So
Moses went down from the mountain to the
people and sanctified the people and
they washed their clothes. And he said
to the people, "Be ready for the third
day. Do not come near your wives." So
part of this sanctification process
involved do not come near your wives.
That means they have to um
>> abstain.
>> Sain. Thank you very much. Uh abstain,
abstain, abstain from the marital
relations. So this was important in the
being sanctified to be sanctified by the
Lord. So uh 1st Samuel chapter 21 brings
us some information concerning that. And
so this was part of the process. A
spiritual preparation was necessary.
Notice that the sacrifice was part of
this sanctification process. Jesus
Christ our sanct is our sacrifice for
us. And that's why I want to read to
you. Let me find it here in in Hebrews
chapter 10 verse 9 and 10. Then he said,
"Lo, I come to do thy will, oh God. He
taketh away the first that he may
establish the second." By the will we
are sanctified through the offering of
the body of Jesus Christ once for all.
So the body the sacrifice of Jesus
sanctifies us. So this is part the
sacrifice which symbolized Christ was
part of the sanctification process.
Prayer and meditation upon God's mercy
also necessary.
>> Amen. Wow. Thank you so much gentlemen.
We are going to take a short break and
we will be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-228-3975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Wow. I hope you were challenged by these
wonderful answers from our panel. We
have we have three of you that's going
to give a closing thought. Let's start
with Pastor Denzy. Uh yes, I want to go
back to that question. You know, the
need to separate is vitally important.
Don't stay there. And again, be careful
with, oh, that's what she wants me to do
and go start going to church for a
little while. But it's a it's a trick.
You got to wait. You got to wait. Put
that into prayer.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> This is really, really important.
>> That's right.
>> Yes.
>> Abuse can lead to murder.
>> Yes, it can.
>> And there are some watching going,
"Well, I wouldn't. And when the devil
get a hold of you, you would be
surprised. What did you do?
>> That's right.
>> So, let's seek the Lord in all things.
>> Mhm. But she did say she left her
abuser.
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> She did.
>> Yes. Go ahead, hun.
>> And on the topic of adornment, be be
careful not to judge somebody
immediately by saying from the moment I
saw a wedding band, I don't want to hear
anything coming out of their mouths.
That's kind of extreme.
>> But know what the Bible teaches. And
once again, go to my website,
johnlomaching.com, because I've seen
this teaching so misunderstood, so
fragmentedly taught that I think that
proper information leads us to
understand two things. That we are
special. Our bodies belong to the Lord
and it should not be a place where
foreign gods are hanging upon it. But
the wedding band does not fall into that
category. Educate yourself and I think
you'll be blessed. johnlacking.com.
You'll enjoy the study.
>> Amen.
>> Thank you. We had a wonderful time in
the excursion of God's word. Thank you
for your thoughtful questions and thank
you for your responses. Until next time,
may God continue to lead you in the word
of God which will lead you to eternity.
Have a blessed day in Jesus.
Heat. Heat.